[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos sobre los
focos en Reino Unido la verdad como está
haciendo la mitad del planeta pero con
luces largas para preguntarnos si Carlos
III nuevo monarca va a conseguir
mantener la unión del Reino Unido y de
la commonwealth vamos a ello con tres
periodistas en este estudio y también
con nuestro corresponsal desde Londres
Delia runategui periodista independiente
bienvenida
mi compañera Natalia Ruiz giraldo
periodista de Franz 24 que acaba de
llegar de Escocia de cubrir todos los
acontecimientos como consecuencia del
fallecimiento de la reina bienvenida
Natalia Gracias y Karen bujes periodista
independiente especializada en turismo y
economía bienvenida Karen gracias
También desde Londres nuestro
corresponsal Daniel postico buenos días
Hola buenos días un saludo desde desde
Londres y
encantado de estar con vosotros
Reino Unido inicia una nueva era hoy en
Primera Plana
la muerte de Isabel II ha dejado un
impacto mediático a nivel Planetario
como pocos acontecimientos se han visto
su figura es sin duda una forma de
analizar el siglo XX y tras la
programación de Carlos III será pasó un
escenario lleno de incertidumbres que
hoy vamos a intentar analizar en el
programa los retos del nuevo monarca
Tantas veces designado como un rey de
transición entre Isabel II y su nieto
Guillermo la propia unidad del reino y
de la commonwealth la muerte de la reina
amenaza con avivar el debate sobre el
sentido de la mancomunidad puede el
republicanismo avanzar en estos lugares
donde Carlos III es ahora el jefe del
Estado repasemos algunas portadas Evelyn
standard recoge las palabras de Carlos
III en su toma de Posesión siento el
peso de la historia
en Escocia se hace la pregunta sobre el
nuevo monarca Salvador de la unidad o
último Rey aquí en Francia el diario
Liberación se acuesta portada con su
habitual juego de palabras la pena de la
pena de Inglaterra tras el fallecimiento
de Isabel II la otra protagonista de
esta etapa que se abre en Reino Unido
sin duda su nueva primera ministra Lis
tras que apenas lleva dos meses en el
poder y ya se ha encontrado con toda
esta situación nada más llegar llega a
su hora dice el daily-mail Muchos medios
la denominan la nueva margaret thatcher
por sus postulados neoliberales bueno
para empezar quiero preguntarles a las
tres Llevamos una semana más de una
semana ya viendo imágenes de Reino Unido
unas sin duda sobre exposición mediática
de todas ellas Con qué imagen se quedan
por su simbolismo de todo lo que estamos
viendo estos días Delia Sí Carlos para
mí lo que más me causó impacto fue justo
antes del anuncio de la muerte de la
reina Isabel segunda cuando las personas
los ingleses comenzaron a acercarse a la
búsqueda palas de forma espontánea para
mostrar su apoyo y su preocupación por
la salud de la reina Muchos de ellos ni
siquiera sabían porque porque estaban
ahí porque la reina no estaba en Boca en
estaba en Escocia los periodistas cuando
estaban ahí les preguntaron por qué
vinieron muchos no sabían muy bien que
decir pero
decían que sentían que tenían que estar
ahí esa emoción se traspasó la pantalla
Natalia una imagen yo creo que la imagen
del cortejo fúnebre a través del Royal
miles de esa gran arteria en edimburgo
desde su llegada no en el momento en que
llega ya después de de balmoral Iba
hasta de la Palacio de Hollywood House y
ver toda esa cantidad de gente y sobre
todo en un espacio más bien pequeño y el
momento en el que pasa ese féretro y ver
esos especies de aplausos un poco
contenidos y las lágrimas creo que esa
es la imagen más fuerte acaba de llegar
de allí de Escocia luego nos vas a
comentar un poco
lo que te encontraste Karen una imagen
Pues yo también iba un poco en relación
a lo que mi compañera Natalia decía que
ese impacto social no en la sociedad de
ver esos rostros Pues conmocionados por
camperizado a su reina no a ese símbolo
también de unidad de estabilidad y a su
icono y quizás es eso es las personas
para mí el centro de atención sobre todo
porque da la sensación de que se ha
perdido una parte de la historia no
porque al final ella enlazaba varias
décadas y varias varias varias partes de
esa época del siglo XX del Siglo 21
entre las épocas colonial y colonial era
el personaje a través del cual podíamos
recorrer la historia del siglo XX es
decir No solo hay una pérdida Quizá para
Reino Unido sino para para la historia
del siglo XX que yo no sé si hay un
personaje en la actualidad que tenga la
importancia del peso de Isabel II a
Delia totalmente la figura de Isabel
segunda representaba eso al principio
fue parte de la historia pero después se
convirtió en protagonista de ella
un reinado de 70 años la mayoría de
personas la hemos visto desde el
principio y ahora lo que crea también
mucha emoción es que no va a estar más
presente esa figura que significaba
también una especie de perenne una
figura que sabíamos que en algún momento
no iba a estar pero ahora que ya no está
cuesta pensar el después vamos a irnos
en este punto a Londres con nuestro
corresponsal Daniel postico Daniel hay
dudas en Reino Unido que es la gran
pregunta ahora sobre si la figura de
Carlos III mantendrá la unidad del país
y de estructuras como la commonwealth
viene una época muy complicada por este
cambio de reinado ellos diferenciaría lo
que es la la estructura interna del
Reino Unido en cuanto a la unidad de las
cuatro naciones que integran el Reino
Unido por un lado está Escocia Que
quiere convocar un referéndum de
Independencia el año que viene
la y por otro lado está Irlanda del
Norte que
debido al brexit los republicanos
irlandeses del sinfín han llegado al
poder y quieren promover un referéndum
de reunificación de la isla de Irlanda
para dentro de 10 años por ejemplo en
Irlanda la figura de Isabel II era muy
respetada incluso por encima de algunos
líderes irlandeses en la República de
Irlanda en cuanto a la commonwealth por
la cual el Reino Unido apostó a partir
del brexit ya el rey es jefe de estado
de 14 de los cuatro países que integran
la commonweb que son las antiguas
colonias y territorias de ultramar y
países que fueron colonias del Reino
Unido hay dos países Perdón que son
Australia y
barbuda y antigua antigua y barbuda que
han pedido ya que quieren convocar un
referéndum de Independencia en los
próximos años entonces
en la figura de Carlos III será
importante para para para para ver hasta
qué punto es respetada en los
territorios de ultramar Sí porque además
la commonwealth era un proyecto de
Isabel II en el que pasó muchas veces la
legitimidad era como web estaba en la
propia figura claro ahora sin esa figura
de Isabel II ahora miembros de la common
web que planteen sus dudas imaginamos
Karen Natalia pues efectivamente creo
que vienen retos importantes porque
claro es que nos encontramos con el
brexit por un lado nos encontramos con
la crisis económica y la inflación y
luego con la cama ungüento donde se van
a plantear también
separarse de lo que es el jefe de estado
tenemos jefe de estado británico que en
el fondo no tiene mucho sentido no
porque es un régimen ya arcaico el tener
una monarquía de estas características y
más y pensamos en países como Australia
o Canadá o Nueva Zelanda no que este año
comunidad cultural y económica en la que
se puede pertenecer incluso saliéndose
incluso no entendiendo a Carlos III como
como jefe de estado totalmente pero yo
creo que lo que hacía esta cohesión
también era la Reina Isabel segunda
porque había una empatía una especie de
carisma que estos países no querían no
querían mantenerse más que nada no por
estar en una monarquía sino por el icono
que representaba a la figura que
representaba a Isabel II ahora que ya no
está más hay que ver realmente quiénes
van a tener un interés para ser parte de
esta comunidad y que no pero ojo No
todos son malas noticias porque justo
este año en junio dos países que estaban
en la Esfera de
protección se puede decir de Francia
cambiaron y se han integrado al Común
vuela Así que no Todos quieren irse hay
nuevos llegados también y eso por parte
de la common Wells Escocia Que quiere
convocar un referéndum de Independencia
Natalia precisamente acaba de llegar de
Escocia Y qué destacaría de todo lo que
del todo lo que ha habido de cómo los
escoceses han vivido estos días creo que
algo que es muy interesante precisamente
porque hay todas esas tensiones no con
con Escocia que quiere
independizarse eso venía incluso pues
desde hace mucho tiempo después del
brexit se volvió a hablar de eso Pero
había una especie de de comunión e
incluso entre los líderes digamos de de
oposición Incluso en la mañana de de
bueno en una de las maña cuando llegaba
el féretro de Isabel II había una
entrevista alyson Johnson quien es la
digamos la presidenta del parlamento
escocés y ella le preguntaron sobre la
reina y era una cantidad de palabras de
muchísimo respeto por la reina ella
justamente se había reunido con Isabel
segunda en junio de este año y decías
una mujer que está al tanto de todos los
dos días de todos los temas se puede
hablar con ella absolutamente entonces
había ese respeto y creo que fue muy
interesante ver precisamente eso es
decir que dejaron de lado tal vez esas
diferencias para darle el respeto a la
reina que sea pues johnston como puede
ser también Nicole storgeon viendo
volvemos a Londres con nuestro
corresponsal Daniel postico viendo todos
los eventos de estos días cabe
preguntarse Daniel si una sociedad
moderna creativa multirrecial y sujetada
tensiones nacionalistas como estamos
viendo puede mantenerse encajada en un
marco tan tradicional a veces incluso
por los las liturgias que hemos me
atrevería a decir medieval como el de
las instituciones británicas Qué tipo de
tensiones y cuestionamientos crea ese
encaje en el Reino Unido de hoy en día
el respeto a la monarquía estaba basado
en el respeto a Isabel segunda falta ver
cuál será la la la reacción de Carlos
III es una sociedad muy moderna muy
multi racial muy abierta económicamente
sin embargo
mantiene una estructura unas tradiciones
ancestrales como se han podido ver ahora
con el con el Duelo y el funeral de la
reina Incluso se han recuperado
ceremonias de los de la época de los
normandos de desde Guillermo El
conquistador falta ver cómo cómo cómo
encaja dentro de esta sociedad moderna
sin la figura de Isabel segunda hay que
decir que el apoyo a la monarquía la el
62% de los británicos están a favor de
la monarquía Aunque hay que tener en
cuenta que únicamente el 24% de los
jóvenes de 18 a 24 años están a favor de
la monarquía entonces hace falta una
modernización de la de la de la
monarquía en el Reino Unido y falta
saber si Carlos III es la persona a Los
73 años capaz de hacer esto complicado
encaje y lo estamos viendo nuestros días
esas tradiciones están arcaicas y al
mismo tiempo estamos hablando de una
sociedad moderna creativa multirracial
parece un poco paradójico no todo esto
sí pero al mismo tiempo creo que hay
algo muy interesante y a veces se hacía
ahínco en eso y es por ejemplo en la
ceremonia de de de en la que ya Carlos
tercero pues hace todas estas firmas el
hecho de que la gente esté allí en el
Palacio de Saint James esperando a que
hagan el anuncio pues son imágenes que
nunca habíamos visto antes no entonces
creo que esto también es decir hay toda
esta parte que puede parecer muy
medieval y al mismo tiempo creo que es
algo que está muy arraigado también en
el pueblo británico entonces habría que
tal vez entrar a analizar si el hecho de
que esta ceremonias y todo este todo
este estos funerales tan largos dejen de
pronto una marca muy fuerte en el pueblo
para que de pronto eso le dé también
fuerza a que la a que la monarquía
continú me voy a ir a hacer una breve
pausa enseguida vamos a seguir
analizando todo lo que está dando de Sí
esta era post Elizabeth de segunda en
Reino Unido pero no va no hace falta
esperar tantas horas como para ver
Alfredo Isabel II nosotros volvemos unos
segundos hasta ahora
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en francés 24 y France 24.com
la guerra está a las puertas de Europa y
recuerda horas sombrías de la historia
la comunidad está organizado para darles
ropa
France 24 está pendiente de los
acontecimientos en Ucrania
con nuestros equipos En el terreno Y
desde nuestros estudios lo mantenemos al
tanto
siga informado siga al día
líbeate egalité
Primera Plana preguntándonos cómo será
el Reino Unido de Carlos III la Nueva
Era que llega al país tras la muerte de
Isabel II lo hacemos con las periodistas
de lermategui Natalia Ruiz giraldo mi
compañera que acaba de llegar de Escocia
Karen bujes y desde Londres nuestro
corresponsal Daniel postico estábamos
hablando antes de ir a la pausa si es
complicado ese encaje de una sociedad
moderna en multicultural y creativa como
es la de Reino Unido con un marco tan
tradicional como el de tradiciones tan
arcaicas como el que estamos viendo
estos días bueno la monarquía de por sí
es algo arcaico en cuanto estructura me
refiero
qué le parece Delia pienso que sí pero
hay dos características sobre todo en la
monarquía de inglesa
la monarquía inglesa siempre ha sido
parte de la identidad del país Por eso
cada vez que se les pregunta a los
ingleses Qué opinan Ellos dicen que es
este algo que los diferencia en otros
países y está muy anclado en lo que es
una identidad nacional por supuesto
están las voces también que dicen que la
monarquía es algo arcaico que es algo
pasado de moda pero las dos cosas a
veces pueden convivir sin problemas ya
que si la monarquía se adapta cómo se ha
venido adaptando lentamente estos
últimos años es posible en todo caso
Este es un momento de Gran de una va a
ser de un momento de transición para el
Reino Unido y el reto que va a tener
este Carlos 13 es enorme porque se le
está se le va a exigir mantener esa
figura que tenía Isabel segunda pero al
mismo tiempo que cambie que cambie que
se modernice lo que ellos llaman la
firma es decir la monarquía
un periodo de transición hablamos en
cualquier caso de Carlos III llega al
poder mayor para llegar al poder como un
monarca de transición entre Isabel II y
Guillermo lo consideran también que es
esa figura de transición Que tanto se
está repitiendo en prensa Natalia
Yo creo que es difícil saberlo Porque
necesitamos ver un poco el cómo va a ser
como como como monarca pero sí puede ser
primero Pues porque su reinado va a ser
claramente
es mucho más cortos segurísimo y también
porque creo que hay hay esa idea de que
la gente quiere ver a William como como
rey a William y a Kate middleton los
quieren ver en el trono entonces puede
ser que sea ese periodo de de de
transición pero creo que hay que un poco
como dar Espera a ver qué tipo de de
monarca va a ser Carlos y de pronto si
va a hacer algún tipo de cambio o si va
a ayudar a mantener finalmente como dice
Delia Pues esa esa tradición y al mismo
tiempo mantenerse suficientemente
moderno para que siga siendo aceptado
entiende que la legitimidad en la
monarquía en Reino Unido se basa en ser
una fuente económica más que en la
tradición caer en usted que conoce bien
la economía y el turismo la monarquía
británica ante todo se justifica por ser
una fuente ingresos impresionante para
el país
Sí así es de hecho es un atractivo
turístico no lo que es la monarquía pero
es cierto que lo que es Reino Unido no
depende del turismo como otros países
como Malta o Croacia no que su producto
interior bruto está hablando que es un
15% es brutal en este caso Reino Unido
es fuerte en el sector Industrial en el
sector comercio y el turismo obviamente
de las principales
fuentes que tienes es la novena
ciudad más visitada no del mundo y
entonces no encontramos con con que en
este caso
el atractivo monárquico se ve ese palpa
en los edificios en las personas la
guardia real Cuando vas allí
como se revitalizado las tazas los
platos con las imágenes de los reyes
exactamente hay tiendas solo de la reina
de este icono y Esto hace que son
atractivos más para y creo que pesa la
muerte el fallecimiento de Isabel Isabel
II creo que va a mantener todavía esa
esencia no monárquica que tanto gustan
otras monarquías Como por ejemplo la de
su país la de España es decir que no
tienen ese anclaje en que sea una fuente
de dividendos para el turismo Daniel
postico Londres Carlos III no cuenta con
la popularidad de su madre está claro y
su legitimidad se basará en un relato
sobre su figura que va que tendrá que
podría apoyarse sobre todo en la defensa
medioambiental eso que ya estamos
escuchando tanto estos días Es verdad
que ha defendido siempre valores
medioambientales entiendo que el
continuismo es la línea que va a seguir
qué podría entonces diferenciar su
reinado el de Carlos III del de su madre
Isabel II mantuvo durante todo su
reinado sus 70 años de reinado una
exquisita neutralidad política que sin
embargo sirvió para para suavizar
relaciones con algunos países te diría
con Estados Unidos que es una su Aliado
tradicional y luego con Francia también
que es el el otro Aliado en Europa de
del Reino Unido y con el que siempre ha
habido tensiones hemos visto como macron
ha expresado su respeto a la reina por
su parte Carlos III Siempre le ha
gustado expresar sus opiniones políticas
en temas medioambientales pero también
en temas de política y esto no ha
gustado a los a los primeros ministros
del Reino Unido él ha prometido mantener
esta neutralidad política pero
faltar a ver si la puede mantener luego
es una cuestión también de energía la
Reina Isabel segunda empezó con 25 años
con mucha energía si bien Ahora era una
mujer mayor pero hasta hace cinco años
mantuvo un ritmo fuertísimo de trabajo
en cambio Carlos empieza con 73 años que
va toda la vida esperando está muy bien
formado lo sabe todo Pero quizás están
en una etapa de subida en la cual la
fuerza que hace falta ahora para para
levantar este país que tiene una crisis
económica tremenda con el brexit una
división social brutal
yo destacaría estas dos cosas primero
dentro de la neutralidad política y
luego la energía
Aprovechando que estoy con tres
periodistas otro ángulo es el del
tratamiento mediático o el exceso
mediático llevamos un montón de días con
el monotema donde ponemos el cursor ante
la muerte de un personaje histórico el
Quizá el más importante en vida Cuando
dejamos de informar cuándo nos pasamos
los medios donde ponemos el cursor de lo
que es excesivo mediáticamente respecto
a todo lo que estamos viendo con la
muerte de Isabel II Delia
yo creo que depende del ángulo que se
que se mire la muerte de Isabel II es un
acontecimiento mundial de es decir es
normal que se que se cubra ampliamente
luego también hay que tener en cuenta
que los medios de comunicación responden
a una lógica de consumo Es decir cuando
hay una noticia importante pero que no
causa mucho interés el cubrimiento va a
ser menor siendo lo contrario obviamente
van a ocurrir lo mucho más al detalle yo
creo que ese es el el punto Cuanto más
las personas el público desean saber
conocer del de la diosa la reina y yo
creo que eso es lo que se le está
ofreciendo actualmente en los medios de
comunicación en Natalia exceso mediático
hay un too much con Isabel II
es difícil porque sea hoy en día con la
televisión con las redes con los
periódicos creo que es muy fácil decir
la veo en todas partes a la reina no
entonces puede ser pero bien lo decía
Delia es un acontecimiento histórico es
algo que le al mundo entero y más allá
de lo que sea es decir histórico de que
haya una cuestión de de historia de de
política también hay toda esa parte un
poco de de paparazzi que tanto ha
alimentado Esa esa prensa y que
finalmente la la realeza británica es
protagonista
pop y tantos productos culturales
audiovisuales que ha tenido es que tiene
todo la historia tiene todo para para
para para para caer en el exceso
mediático también al mismo tiempo no
Karen se ha convertido en un icono pero
es de su coronación en el 53 que fue la
primera televisada que no se hizo antes
Entonces ya ella ya ella por eso como
cuando comentaba Delia yo ya veía Una
simbiosis entre una monarquía
tradicional y algo más moderna por lo
menos ella lo intentaba No desde desde
su inicio y claro De ahí hasta ser
pintada por Andy warhol fotografiada por
Annie es decir que los Beatles Freddie
Mercury la mencionaron Godzilla de Queen
es decir nos encontramos una serie de
elementos que han hecho que tenga
presencia también en series como Los
Simpson es decir una serie de elementos
que ha hecho que que es icono y que se
acerque más al pueblo incluso creo que
que lo intentó hacer con las mujeres de
su nieto con Megan tratar esos problemas
raciales también y acercarse más a esta
sociedad multicultural de la que estamos
hablando
al reinado de Isabel II no a todo esto
vamos a centrarnos en otra de las
figuras para marcar esta nueva era que
se abre en Reino Unido de la que se ha
hablado muy poco últimamente pero es que
es impresionante llega una nueva primera
ministra una nueva Premier la que
sustituye a Boris Johnson Liz tras
ganadora de las primarias de los toris y
a la semana bueno a la semana no a los
dos días se encuentra para que con todo
esto para gestionar la muerte de Isabel
II casi sin tiempo de reacción Aunque
Ahora parece que hay una tregua política
no en todo lo que estamos viendo delias
sí al menos hasta lo que sea el funeral
el lunes de la ex Reina Isabel II así
hay una tregua porque es lo que
mediáticamente se habla que solamente de
ello pero es cierto que hay una nueva
Primer Ministro que causa muchas
preocupaciones sobre todo porque por sus
convicciones políticas neoliberales se
confiesa como admiradora de margaret
thatcher la Dama De Hierro Así que es
ahí hay mucha expectativa sobre porque
en este momento el Reino Unido
Inglaterra está viviendo un momento de
crisis en varios sectores estructurales
del país salud energía atención pública
una inflación de más del 10% entonces
hay muchas expectativas por las medidas
vamos a preguntarle a nuestro
corresponsal en el póstico el Duelo por
Isabel II paralizado por unos días la
tensión política y el arranque de La era
del issstrass hay elementos suficientes
para creer que vuelve el tacherismo de
su mano como comentábamos con Delia
Daniel una gran defensora
Ella es una gran defensora de las ideas
de sacher
en cuanto a la mínima intervención del
estado en la economía al Libre Mercado
en cuanto a la reducción
de los subsidios sociales de las ayudas
sociales y ella de hecho la promesa que
ha hecho a los miembros de su partido a
las bases de su partido es reducir los
impuestos una reducción de los impuestos
Y
esta es la idea detrás ahora la realidad
es que ella no tiene un mandato fuerte
porque está dentro del mandato de
conexión son quedan apenas dos años de
mandato
ella ha sido elegida únicamente por lo
por un 0,3% de la población que son los
miembros del partido conservador las
bases del partido conservador y luego la
situación del país con una crisis
tremenda con una inflación disparada que
está en el 10,1 y que llegará el 18% en
enero según las previsiones con la
energía la factura de la energía
disparada Entonces ella tendrá que dar
unas ayudas sociales muy importante
incrementando la deuda entonces
rebajar los impuestos e incrementar la
deuda de estado es algo que algunos
economistas dicen que es no es factible
Entonces ella no podrá desarrollar lo
que realmente ha prometido Pues no sé si
como escenario global nos podríamos
quedar con que esta es la vuelta del
tacherismo en el siglo XXI sin el
soporte de una reina popular como Isabel
II que vertebrará todo eso parece pues
vaya escenario no se le queda al Reino
Unido vaya
preocupante a partir del funeral porque
claro hasta ahora hay una tregua pero
veremos a partir de cuando todo esto
Muchísimas gracias Karen Natalia Delia
es un placer Gracias también a nuestro
corresponsal Daniel desde desde Londres
y a todos ustedes les esperamos la
próxima semana quien en Primera Plana
gracias
[Música]